I read a headline that said the
mainstream media is
dying um what shifts do you see
happening you're talking about that
things are shifting and you're a
disruptor yourself what's your opinion I
I love the fact that they're they're
sitting there scared do you realize one
policy by president can destroy 90% of
mainstream media you know what this
policy is let me break it down for you
watch this so if all of a sudden the
president goes out there and says hey
American people do you know how many
countries in the world allow
pharmaceutical companies to advertise on
TV and social media how many two two I
don't know that yeah do you know what
those two countries are what America and
New Zealand why New Zealand so Germany
doesn't no Canada doesn't allow no Italy
no Spain Brazil no Russia no UK no it's
only us and New
Zealand why not well because
pharmaceutical companies are giving so
much money to these media companies and
these media company announcers and host
and talent have to do whatever they can
with these pharmaceutical companies
because if they don't a lot of the
profit of these big media companies
coming from who Pharma big Pharma so
what if a president goes out there and
does an executive order saying moving
forward pharmaceutical companies can no
longer advertise just like you know what
company can't advertise on TV today they
can sell their product but you never see
their commercials on TV what is it
when's the last time you saw a cigarette
commercial when's the last time you saw
a BAP commercial what the president
makes the case and you and I sit there
and we're like you know what he's got a
good point she's got a good point why
are we allowing this why should we allow
him to do this kind of stuff why don't
you allow the doctor to make the
recommendation to me and I'll take the
counsel from the doctor but I don't need
a billion of advertising budget for you
know this Pharma thing that I got to
take so to
me there's three things holding them
back one is Big Pharma advertising
number two is Boomers that still watch
TV and number number three you know what
the last one is that scares the crap out
of mainstream media is the one thing
they have control of that basketball
teams like the Suns and Salt Lake Utah
some of these teams are disrupting it is
called Sports If Sports goes on digital
Hulu Amazon if sports teams say moving
forward you want to watch your sons Go
download the sun Suns app it's 999 a
month and you can watch us what if the
Lakers go on their own app what if the
Knicks go on their own app what if Tampa
B goes on their own app oh my God we
don't need the contracts anymore no what
if Super Bowl goes on all these other
apps and OT start giving those contracts
so mainstream media is shivering right
now with disruption and they're in the
begging mode but behind closed doors
some of these Oldtimer guys that are on
their way out they're like man we better
get our money look what happened to
Disney last 12 18 months they lost $195
billion give or take valuation 56% their
stock is down Bob Iger just come out
came out today and said he's going to be
stepping on by 2026 here's one of the
greatest Executives we've had the last
30 38 years 40 years has done some of
the biggest deals Pixar Star Wars who
he's bought everybody and now right of a
lifetime becomes finishing up the way
you are right now because you forgot who
your customer was you went from
realizing you know what the customer for
you know when Disney's number one
customers the person who's got control
of the remote control who is that you
and I who are we we're parents not the
kids they forgot we're the customer how
does Bob Iger forget that you and I are
customer what happened to him the moment
you forget the number one rule know your
customer he forgot they're getting
destroyed backto backto back movies that
are flops so mainstream Medias uh is
being clobbered and guys like Elon Dana
sports team some of these other guys
couple policies if those things go
through their lifespan is 5 10 15 years
maybe shorter what is your thoughts
about jz's behaviors if they're not
watching live games the NFL trying to
Pivot to creators what do you think the
power of creators is and and maybe why
the NFL as a as a corporation is doing
this they have no choice I mean Mr Beast
does a video gets 80 million views 100
million you don't have a choice the
Super Bowl's 104 million views so think
about a guy that starts a YouTube
channel got three 400 million
subscribers does a video gets 100
million views and you are the NFL your
name is Roger godell and you say to
advertise well let me tell you the
reason why it's so important to spend
$5.2 million for a 302 commercial on
Super Bowl it's because you get 104
million people watching is the most
watched sporting event in America right
but these young guys are no longer
watching it where are they getting their
stuff they're maybe watching highlights
they're just going watching reruns maybe
they're watching post game they kind of
want the fastest thing to get so they
got to go get the younger people to be
participating look what happened all of
a sudden all these Chiefs games are
selling out why all these you know
everywhere they go go on the road the
Jets wherever they go some because
Taylor Swift is dating Travis Kelce and
Taylor Swift's got a few hundred million
followers they're understanding who's in
charge and they do not like that this is
a scary Direction it's going those who
pivot and adjust accordingly will win
but the days of bullying are behind us
the days of guys leveraging their pulpit
and the fact that we're CBS we're ABC
we're such and such no no no guess what
we're Mr Beast where's Sean canel where
this Joe Rogan where this this oh my God
we kind of need those guys to come and
help us out with this of course they are
this is going to flip in ways nobody is
expecting except for guys like you guys
like us who are content creators the
future looks bright for those who create
great content this is just a beginning
for us yeah yeah and so you have some
predictions and some thoughts about 2024
yes let's go macro first and then let's
go specific for creators so macro what
are your predictions you just mentioned
those who if you don't pivot you're in
trouble so how do we prepare what do you
see coming so first of all it's going to
be very chaotic year I mean you're
you're gonna see uh uh uh Trump Biden
you saw yesterday Newsome Des santis
politically it's going to be crazy
interest rates corporations having to
pay their payments if interest rates
don't go down people are worried if
interest rates do go down let's just say
right now mortgage rates are at 7 and a
quarter 30 or fixed you got a 720 740
let's say it's 7 and a half percent
if rates and by the way Real Estate
Value hasn't dropped it keeps going
higher so they're increasing the rates
and real estate value is still going
higher and people are not selling comes
because they're not dropping a 2.85 3%
interest rate that they got a year and a
half ago two years ago but what happens
if all of a all of a sudden they lower
the rates what happens if Powell is
forced to lower the rates what happens
there these real estate values are going
to Skyrocket so what happens if it
skyrockets the whole concept of
the rich got richer and the poor got
poor it's going to be on steroids what
happens the next 12 months on steroids
you could
potentially the IPO Market's going to
come back in 2024 you're going to see
the IPO Market in 2023 is one of the
worst IPO Seasons we ever had 2023
horrible
2024 you're going to see some IPOs
coming out 2025 on fire if somebody on
the right gets elected as a president if
you remember the day Trump got elected
as a president stock market the next day
boom Skyrocket way before he even did
anything with policies today uh the left
is not happy with the president that
they have the right is not happy with
the president that the left has today
with Joe Biden the numbers are not
looking good it's so bad right now that
yesterday a governor from Florida who's
running for president is debating a
governor from California Newsome who's
not running for office right now why are
they on the stage do they know something
the rest of us don't know this is a very
chaotic year 2024 so how do you
capitalize when Co happened what
happened all of a sudden next thing you
know meet Kevin 1.5 million subscribers
wow this guy's great well who is this
guy oh Graham Stefan who is that guy
people were popping up left and right
and they were doing daily lives and
here's what's going on let me give you
an update on this let me give you an
update on this 2024 if it's a chaotic
year the talent who is able to react to
comments quickly and get creative and
start using some of this new AI that's
coming out that's allowing you to import
a 3-hour podcast that you did and this
AI spits out your top 20 clips and which
one it edits it for you it puts video
over it it puts captions over it it
gives you a title and a description to
post so what if the guys that are
talented people and they have an angle
that's different than others and they
leverage AI I think I think it's a very
weird year 2024 in a positive way and
whenever people are are afraid which a
lot of people are going to be afraid in
2024 few sharpens listening 2024 is
going to be here a lot of people going
to be afraid if you enjoyed this podcast
and are ready for some deep dive YouTube
strategy just go to think
masterclass.com to get access to my
1hour OnDemand YouTube strategy class
you'll be looking over my shoulder as I
share my best tips and you can watch it
on Demand right now at think
masterclass.com